hallo leute ich will eure mal wanne mw
im letzten video hat auch dann der
letzte gecheckt dass es weh und dieser
pullover ist nicht mein merge auch wenn
ich das gerne so hätte ich habe den
online gefunden und dachte mir so es
kann doch nicht sein mw ach ja und
vielleicht gehen wir ganz kurz über die
roten haare auf instagram und hektik
habe ich alles schon released wenn ihr
mir da nicht folgt selber schuld und ich
hab jetzt rote haare
mehr gibt es dazu eigentlich auch nicht
zu sagen leute es ist kurz vor ostern
und eigentlich wollte ich ganz soviele
poster relays videos machen aber
irgendwie hab ich dann doch muss dazu
bekommen vielleicht liegt es an dem lock
down an der pandemie dass man zu hause
sitzt und irgendwie dann doch mal was
süßes backen möchte auf jeden fall
machen wir heute eine harry potter
klosterpforte mit maulwurfs kuchen und
schönen goldschmuck oben drauf weil der
niklaus fantastische wesen ist ja so
eine art maulwurf der flyer ist ein aus
großbritannien stammende c't ihr wesen
und verwandt mit dem schnabeltier das
sind unsere daten das sind unsere
zutaten für den schokokuchen zwar mail
kakaopulver zucker salz hafer milch
rapsöl selter und das zeug hier
der besondere tour ist an diesem kuchen
ist nämlich dass er eigentlich vegan ist
wenn man die deko abzieht aber da kann
man auch vegane deko nehmen also man
kann natürlich hier auf machen was man
will aber gegen so ein schönes überall
hat keiner aus und dann würde sagen
fangen wir an mit dem
deshalb das nicht von mir ich verlinke
euch das in der video beschreibung wenn
ich dran denke erinnert mich einfach den
kommentaren fast wieder vergessen habe
sorry zerrissen die trockenen zutaten
vermischt werden wie mehl kakaopulver
zucker salz von einer packung backpulver
und diese zutaten werden jetzt erst mal
miteinander verrührt und jetzt geht es
weiter mit den feuchten zutaten ganz
wichtig in unserem fall vom rudel wasser
es gibt gerade aus als habe ich im
sandkasten einfach irgendwie so eine
kampe zusammengestellt und das übel
[Musik]
sondern verrühren dann miteinander gibt
dort gedacht ist ein show gezeigt was
mit anis geburtstagskuchen
sie ist meine beste freundin verliebt
der harry potter und schreibt ihr in die
kommentare
wer mich schon ein bisschen verfolgt
weiß ich habe immer einen trick auf
lager
fazit kein kuchen fest unternehmen noch
das restliche öl was außer dem glas ich
mitgekommen ist mit macht warnt ein
bisschen an der leute feiern ostern
schreibt meine kommentare wisst ihr
überhaupt warum man ostern feiert ich
muss sagen das ist ein bisschen komisch
zu heutigen zeit dass man so christliche
fest gefeiert
also keiner falls mehr wegen muss also
wegen ihres also kann ich rede nicht
davontragen
[Musik]
und der kommt jetzt in den ofen eine
stunde bei 190 grad eine stunde aber
sehen uns heute abend wieder dabei und
wir sehen uns dann in einer stunde
wieder
wir sehen unsere drei stunden wieder
oder so in der zwischenzeit ja okay zu
früh gefreut jetzt bereiten wir
natürlich alles was wir in drei stunden
gleich weitermachen können natürlich
lassen wir die zeit nicht umsonst
vergeuden und können uns jetzt um die
creme aus kuchen autos gucken maulwurfs
maulwurfs kommt das ist so ein schweres
wort maulwurfs gucken in einem august
kuchen gibt's dann kriegen die machen
wir jetzt das ist unsere pflanzliche
schlag creme gesehen jetzt man nicht
darüber was für dinger da drin sind wir
das sieht alles sehr nach e und i und ii
und das ganze drin
[Musik]
bodies zu ultra weil das meiste vom weiß
ich weiß sie ist einfach so weiß weiß
dass bei erkan und stefan große bruder
druck hast du da bin ich so voll kluger
knutschte und vanillezucker das ist
vanillinzucker dass künstliches aroma
und rein in die masse das wird jetzt
gerührt und dann schlagen wir jetzt auf
fließe aber strom nicht aber das sieht
gut aus so das ist unser vegane schlag
reden sondern sie krämer schokoladen
splitter damit dass stracciatella und
das natürlich noch mal miteinander muss
man probieren sie bekommen jetzt im
kühlschrank und wir kümmern uns um die
deko wir haben ja mal eine auswahl an
süßigkeiten vorbereitet die wir jetzt
alle mit gold anstrengen werden dafür
habe ich goldenes lebensmittel spray
gefunden was ich mega cool finde ich das
noch nie vorher gesehen habe ich hatte
schon mal für die krabben burger falls
sich da ein oder andere erinnert bunte
lebensmitteln gab es zum sprühen
deuce
durch sprühfarbe stimmt halt ein
bisschen jetzt probieren so ein schoko
aus den brand nicht zu
da wollte sie zu viel besser sieht cool
aus
[Musik]
wie cool naja es ist alltag
ja sag mal wie spät ist das denn jetzt
geworden 8 uhr unser gucken ist jetzt
fertig gebacken und sieht nur
fantastisch aus und jetzt könnten wir
ihn und dann kam die creme drauf und
dann kommen die übernahme jetzt hitze
zwar und sehr guten macht es die arbeit
ganz leicht und zeigt uns wo wir
schneiden und zwar da wo er anfängt dann
zu seinem werk zu werden
das zeige ich mir diesen luftbläschen
gucken experten könnte jetzt vielleicht
mal die kommentare schreiben ist sieht
das so gut aus oder müssen die fehler
seien somit komisch der richtwert
opladen hat ist doch toll hier nicht so
genau so soll es aussehen
[Gelächter]
ich komme eigentlich so eine küche wo
ich mich so hinweg
das ist doch perfekt für mich und dass
man sich zerbröseln muss wir probieren
den kuchen oder wir sind der beste
sprung hier gegessen habe ich glaube das
liegt daran dass hier wirklich nicht
viel zucker drin ist obwohl wir keine
schale rein gemacht haben aber im
vergleich zu diesem schokotorte gesetz
gemacht habt kann man davon was essen
ohne gleich das gefühl zu haben okay
eine gabe reicht es ist aber sehr viel
nicht verzagen macht mit dem rest
einfach denn wie man das jetzt machen
zerkrümeln einfach nur mein gott ich
fühle mich wie meine oma in der kirche
wird auch immer auf einem stuhl gesessen
so einem hocker der sich bewegen könnte
die hocker mit rollen
wirkliches gucken dazwischen also hört
sich die backmischung benutzt habe hatte
ich nicht so
[Musik]
der flug mit seinem das stück holding
für meine cake pops immer wenn ihr was
übrig habt was für was von halle und
kuchen isst nimmt zu cake pops
jeder liebt cake pops und gerade zu
ostern kann man so gute machen die dann
halt aus dem mini ich weiß dass diese
schon google fehlt schokostückchen also
wenn ihr das süßer machen wollen macht
schokostückchen in euren schokokuchen
ich weiß nicht wie geil diese ansicht
ist es kann sein schicksal zu
akzeptieren es jetzt einfach die kamera
so steht reicht es doch gar nicht so
schlecht sagt ihr trainer kommen 20 mal
es gibt andere probleme hier ist unsere
schlagregen die wirklich so weiß ist wie
nichts anderes auf dieser welt es wäre
ja kein maulwurf kommen wenn nicht
bananen reinkommen und daher an die
kirchen mark habe ich kirchen abgetropft
aus dem glas ist vielleicht die banane
bresser hier macht man die banane oder
draußen wo wir machen außen banane als
rand und innertkirchen an die kirchen
kalifornien ja es ist jetzt noch ein
original maulwurfs kuchen mit kirchens
handlung bananen an der große moment mal
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass da
oben drauf
studieren also ich zeig euch einmal so
sieht es aus und ihr hetzt recht auf
eine kindergärtnerin zu reden und wir
machen wie schoko krümmel krücken darauf
leute aus meiner generation ist mir
aufgefallen dass viele dinge die in der
jugend und kindheit total wichtig waren
wie maulwurfshügel später im normalen
leben nichts mehr einfach keine rolle
mehr spielen ich meine es liegt
wahrscheinlich daran dass ich in der
stadt leben und keinen garten habe aber
das kind waren mein ding für mich neues
buch ist fertig war ja so was jetzt
kommt
ich schaue ich mal wie geil diese
aussehen hallo ba sieht das auch die
kinder riegel sehe ich aus wie so kleine
goldbarren und jetzt kommt das beste
leute wir haben einen voldemort schoko
yahoo kommen dahin wird man den so
dachte man doch eingelegt werden das
sieht alles mega fancy aus jetzt ist nur
das problem ich bin perfektionist und
ich kann so was nicht anfang ich denke
halt dass man so sicher runter arbeitet
solchen so aussehen als ob das so alles
aus dem loch raus fällt also ist das
hier schon konditor lifestyle am start
da kommen sie thaler rein
ja also mit den orange hat es wirklich
am besten geklappt so ab damit im
kühlschrank ich bin
er sieht schon megacool aus ich hoffe
ich kann morgen ein schönes bild mit dem
morgen wenn es schön tageslicht ist und
so dann zeige ich euch wieder jetzt
wirklich aussieht aber ich denke man
kann es auch so schon gut erkennt ich
hoffe er schafft bis morgen das ist
wirklich sagen google oder fragen
[Musik]
so jetzt sind wir beim geburtstagskind
angetragen zwei haushalte keine sorge
anschneiden den kuchen an
sieht aus wie ein marshmallow geräten
ist auch das alles normal
und jetzt sogar moment the finale of
waiting for the hammer die sieht gar
einmal so schlecht aus hier an der seite
banane fällt es oft eine banane rat und
in den kirchen
ich mags geburtstagskuchen isla kate mit
maulwurfs kuchen und in vegan
das schema der allerwichtigste frage
wieso eine zuckerfreie schwarzwälder
kirschtorte gefallen bis das nicht mal
wieder gängigen smr anderes video
abonnieren
hier noch eine katze